It's a bit ironic that although theoretical computer science
is very precise, there are sometimes very confusing naming conventions,
and since many students,
at least those I have had have been confused by this,
I just quickly wanted to clear one thing up.
You will sometimes read that the Halting Problem
is semi-decidable
and we have to say that it's un-decidable,
so which one of these 2 is it?
Is it undecidable or is it half-way decidable?
And paradoxically,
it's both, and let me explain why.
So assume that we have a program, P,
and we want to determine if it halts,
so we want to know, does the program stop at a certain point in time,
and the answer to that, as you know,
can either be yes or no.
Now let's think about the 2 cases that are possible.
So the first one of those 2 cases is that
P stops, and my question for you is,
if P does stop,
can we a yes after a finite amount of time?